si l'on pensait que les relations russie
otan ne peuvent pas être pire qu'elles
le sont aujourd'hui alors attachez vos
ceintures
reuters a rapporté ce matin que l'otan
envisager des scénarios de dissuasion
pour les régions de la mer baltique et
de la mer noire impliquant
éventuellement des armes nucléaires
déployées par voie aérienne est ce la
voie que l'otan est prête à suivre
c'est la voie de la dissuasion nous
devons faire comprendre très clairement
à la russie qu'en fin de compte nous
sommes prêts et c'est aussi la doctrine
de la dissuasion à déployer de tels
moyens de dissuasion à l'avance afin que
personne n'ait l'idée d'attaquer les
partenaires de l'otan dans l'est région
de la mer baltique et de la mer noire
bon la ministre sortante de la défense
allemande veut certainement partir avec
éclat mais l'évocation seul que des
hommes de dissuasion nucléaire puisse
être utilisée semble inquiétante je ne
parle même plus du fait que c'est
l'allemagne qui menace la russie
d'annihilation apparemment les leçons de
la seconde guerre mondiale n'ont pas été
retenus dans le contexte des appels à la
dissuasion militaire de la russie les
forces de l'otan se rapproche de nos
frontières la ministre allemande de la
défense devrait bien savoir comment cela
s'est terminé par le passé pour
l'allemagne et l'europe la sécurité en
europe ne peut être que collective
elle ne doit pas compromettre les
intérêts de la russie néanmoins c'est
l'otan qui n'est pas prêt pour un
dialogue sur un pied d'égalité à ce
sujet de plus le plan de l'otan sur la
dissuasion en afghanistan s'est soldée
par la catastrophe à laquelle le monde
entier fait face aujourd'hui après que
le temps a expulsé mi-octobre des
diplomates russes est la russie outre la
suspension des travaux de la mission de
liaison militaire de l'alliance à moscou
a interrompu l'activité de son bureau
d'information la mission permanent de la
russie auprès de l'alliance sera aussi
suspendu à partir du 1er novembre pour
contacter moscou le ton doit désormais
passer par l'ambassadeur russe à
bruxelles pas très pratique pour la
communication l'otan après avoir suivi
la voie de l'évolution s'est retrouvé
dans la situation de 1949 en fait elle
lui aujourd'hui selon les schémas de la
guerre froide les principaux efforts
visant à parer une soi-disant menaces de
l'est
d'ailleurs avant de renvoyer les
diplomates russes le secrétaire général
de l'otan et un stoltenberg parlait dans
une conversation avec le chef de la
diplomatie russe sergueï lavrov de
l'intéressant sert de le temps de
normaliser ses relations avec la russie
une façon de parler apparemment respond
chine en fait cette confrontation n'est
pas nouvelle elle dure depuis des années
ce que nous avons entendues du
secrétaire général de l'otan et en
stoltenberg et du ministre allemand de
la défense s'est justement une phrase
ordinaire que l'on ajoute à la fin de
chaque déclaration néanmoins nous sommes
ouverts au dialogue mais le véritable
dialogue entre la russie et l'otan
n'existe plus depuis des années en
particulier en ce qui concerne les
invitations aux nouveaux pays à devenir
membre de l'alliance atlantique
évidemment cela donne matière à
réflexion pour la russie
l'absence de dialogue en bonne
intelligence entre la russie et le temps
nous y sont presque habitués ce serait
bien que la confrontation entre la
russie et le temps reste uniquement
verbal